Instagram is out this morning with some
self-reflection for 2017 it's your
interview pop star Selena Gomez
maintains her title as the most followed
celebrity she is more than 130 million
followers you go Selena soccer star
Cristiano Ronaldo comes in second he's
got 116 followed by Ariana Grande she's
got 115 Beyonce mrs. Carter at 108
million and Kim kardashian-west
at 104 Beyonce by the way also enjoys
the honor of the most liked photo the
now mother of three cuz she had twins
Noor you know about having twins got
more than 11 million likes for February
announcement that she was pregnant with
her twins a boy and a girl that they've
named sir in I dunno about twins but I
never posed for a photo like that the
most linked video is Ronaldo showing off
his new Bugatti he scored more than 4.7
million likes and nearly 20 million
views love is the top hashtag of the
year that's good that's followed by
fashion photo of the day photography and
art and here's something new in the
lineup the face filter used and the most
Instagram stories is the puppy filter no
filters were added in May and they
continue to make Instagram popular yeah
and we are happy to share this Nora will
take part in an Instagram live on the
official Instagram account this morning
to take a closer look at the Year in
Review we're proud of course to be the
first media organization ever to do this
go to at Instagram at 11:30 a.m. Eastern
and you can also follow us at CBS this
morning okay cool so you'll be there at
11:30 yes so it's gonna be live on the
Instagram okay Instagram feed yeah okay
yeah but it'll actually be on give me on
both of our Instagram feeds yes yeah oh
the Instagram and mine but they haven't
many more followers than I do
we're gonna go to yours 11:30